I'm experiencing numbness and slight discomfort on the right side of the prostate area from the sit bone to the scrotum and an occasional stinging feeling near the scrotal area.
I also have my own chills all over my body during waking hours and normal activity. I do not experience chills while arresting.
I also feel my own flaws and tired feeling. I assume these annoying and uncomfortable experiences are the result of the cancer spreading.
Well, and that is the possible reason that the cancer could be spreading. It just could be, you know, the cancer is irritating under that's affecting that area too.
So, you could be something else too. So, you know, this person has prostate cancer, I believe. You could have prosthetic hypertrophy along with it that could be causing neurological damage too.
The only way to know that your cancer spreading or not is to go back and do the same test that diagnosed it in the first place, the size of it in the first place.
I consider that I'm in the minor pain category and the comparative pain scale chart producer cutters, please suggest some remedies that will significantly reduce these experiences.
Note that two ibuprofen soft gel capsules today significantly reduce, eliminate the chills and block feeling and the uncomfortable nagging numbness after experiences for the better part of the day.
I do not take two capsules a day regularly, but two capsules a few times to monitor the effect.
Okay, so if ibuprofen helps in two soft gel capsules, probably 400 milligrams of ibuprofen, you know, that's not a whole lot of ibuprofen.
So that I would consider, you know, what would be a possible nutritional approach that would be a more natural approach.
Well, then you think about things like up in your curcumin.
It just goes back to your anti-inflammatory. So, like curcuclear.
It would be.
It would be an option.
And maybe the liposomal form of curcuclear, which is the liposomal curcuclear.
Or, and I think of the clear inflame, which has a bunch of other anti-inflammatories, like Boswellia, Stiggy Nettle, White Willow Bark, Rosemary, I think, and some other anti-inflammatories.
So I would think I would up those whatever I have like inflammatory type symptoms.
My, my new favorite is the liposomal curcuclear.
That I've just kept on my desk and I just gulp it right out of the model. So I take maybe a tablespoon.
If I'm having issues a couple of times a day like today, I took several times today.
So, or the, like, the curcuclear capsules work too. So anti-inflammatories would be the go-to thing.